[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Oftentimes, we
hear that there aren't women
in tech, and that's not true.
It's that we can't see them.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
Every individual
has their own unique
perspective, and all of them
are necessary to create a future
that we all want to live in.
DIRK PRIMBS: There is
a perception out there
that tech and engineering,
somehow, is not for women.
And that's simply
not based on fact.
Programs like Women Techmakers
help countering that.
They showcase women who are
impressively skilled engineers.
And bringing more female
talent to software and hardware
which [? tackles ?]
every one of us,
is one of the key reasons
why running such a program
is important.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: The
mission of Women Techmakers
is to increase the visibility,
community, and resources
for women, which is reinforcing
for the women that might
want to join the industry.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: We have
Google Developer Group
organizers, whose focus is to
understand what are the needs,
and to create these
experiences and events that
are going to best serve
those women locally.
AZZURRA RAGONE: Being
a Woman Techmaker
is something that
completely changed my life.
You can learn from each
kind of different event.
You learn something that then,
you can apply on your job.
NATALIE PISTUNOVICH:
Women Techmakers events
taught me more than anything,
whatever you want to start,
start rolling.
Things will happen.
You see someone does something.
You learn by doing,
and then others
learn by seeing others do.
DIRK PRIMBS: You have
access to content.
You have access to
other communities.
You're part of a global
movement, essentially.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: We're
learning from each other,
sharing our best practices.
And from that, we hope that
we can spread our learnings
to the community globally.
NATALIE PISTUNOVICH: When
you see people succeed
by themselves, and you
see this living organism,
I don't know how else
to describe this.
It's just community at its best.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
These days are
filled with inspiration that
allows you to really carry on
for the next couple of
months or for the next year.
DIRK PRIMBS: Women Techmaker
strives to create role models,
really.
AZZURRA RAGONE: If
you have a role model,
you feel empowered because you
say, I can do the same thing.
You can be what you can see.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: All of
these women that are here today
are GDG organizers, and
they're all volunteers.
And they're bringing
their passion to life
because they care.
And it's a special time
for us to give them
the recognition that they
deserve with all the hard work
that they're doing.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: When you
come to Women Techmakers event,
it's about coming together as
community, as a sisterhood.
One of the best ways that
someone can get involved
is to join our
membership program.
We have communities and
scholarships to help you.
So by joining Women
Techmakers, you're
a part of a movement
of women helping women.